AND WE'VE JUST SEEN AND VERIFIED
NEW VIDEO SHOWING THE STIFF
RESISTANCE FROM THE UKRAINIANS
THE RUSSIANS ARE RUNNING INTO.
>> A RUSSIAN UNIT MOVES
CAUTIOUSLY THROUGH THE OUTSKIRTS
OF KHARKIV, THEIR GOAL TO SEIZE
A NEARBY MILITARY AIR FIELD AND
PROPERTY, THEY'RE PROGRESS MAKES
THEM A TARGET FOR UKRAINIAN
DEFENDERS HIDING NEARBY.
SUDDENLY, AN AMBUSH.
THE RUSSIANS FALL BACK, THEIR
SOLDIERS TRYING TO SHELTER
BEHIND THEIR HUM-V TYPE
VEHICLES.
THEIR CHAOTIC RETREAT SEEN HERE
FROM ANOTHER ANGLE, ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF THE STIFF RESISTANCE
THE RUSSIANS ARE ENCOUNTERING
FROM MOBILE UKRAINIAN UNITS WHO
KNOW THE LAY OF THE LAND.
BUT THE RUSSIANS CAN'T ESCAPE,
THEY RUN INTO FURTHER TROUBLE,
APPARENTLY SURROUNDED.
AT LEAST ONE OF THEIR TRUCKS IS
DISABLED.
A RESIDENT TELLING A REUTERS
JOURNALIST, ONE OF THE RUSSIANS
WAS KILLED IN THE FIREFIGHT.
>> AFTER WE'VE KILLED THIS ONE,
THE OTHERS RUN AWAY.
THERE WERE SOME 12 TO 15 PEOPLE,
THAT'S IT.
WE WILL WIN.
THEY WON'T TAKE KHARKIV.
THEY HAVE RUN BACK TO WHERE THEY
CAME FROM.
>> Reporter: UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
SURROUND THE ABANDONED VEHICLES,
CELEBRATING A SMALL VICTORY IN A
CONFLICT WHERE THEY SHOULD HAVE
NO CHANCE OF HOLDING OFF THE
ENEMY.
OFF CAMERA, ONE OF THEM SAYS,
AND THAT'S HOW WE MEET THE
[ BLEEP ]
RUSSIAN ARMY, BUT THIS PLATOON'S
DAY IS NOT OVER, THE ENEMY IS
STILL IN THE AREA, THEY DASH
FORWARD TO PROJECT RPGs, A
RAG-TAG ARMY THAT IS, FOR NOW,
HOLDING OFF A FAR SUPERIOR
FORCE.
BUT FOR CIVILIANS HERE, THE
RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE IS TERRIFYING.
THIS APARTMENT BLOCK IN KHARKIV
HIT BY MILITARY FIRE SATURDAY
NIGHT, THANK FAMILY, MOST OF THE
RESIDENTS WERE SHELTERING IN THE